la lluvia no ha parado en pakistán las
inundaciones y las precipitaciones
monzónicas han afectado a más de 30
millones de personas que representan el
15 por ciento de la población del país
surasiático desde el mes pasado 900
ciudadanos murieron y 184 mil se
convirtieron en desplazados a campos de
socorro en todo el país
y
mira esta casa la familia tiene nueve
niños y no tienen sostén familiar y
obvio toda la noche y no había nadie
para ayudarlos al menos alguien debería
proporcionarles una tienda de campaña o
una sábana de plástico para salvar a los
niños no hay electricidad no hay agua
potable
he perdido a mis nietos en la inundación
y algunos siguen desaparecidos estoy muy
preocupada
pakistán instó a la comunidad
internacional a que ayude mientras el
país lucha por hacer frente a los daños
causados por lo que al ministro de
cambio climático ha llamado el desastre
humanitario inducido por el clima de
proporciones épicas pero las personas
afectadas criticaron al gobierno por su
falta de acción
a todos los hogares cajas ropas nada se
pudo salvar nadie vino aquí a ofrecer
simpatía ningún funcionario del gobierno
vino a preguntarnos si podríamos salvar
a nuestros hijos nuestro trigo o nuestro
ganado todo se ha arruinado
no hay ayuda del gobierno nuestros niños
se mueren de hambre nuestro ganado se
muere de hambre la enfermedad se ha
desatado aquí hay mosquitos a nadie le
importa a dónde debemos ir cuidamos la
nipona según la autoridad nacional de
gestión de desastres 150 kilómetros de
carreteras y 82 mil viviendas han
resultado dañadas en las últimas 24
horas